bonsoir alexis conseil de défense
sanitaire présidée par emmanuel macron
et puis maintenant le conseil des
ministres selon des sources proches du
gouvernement il s'agirait de prendre des
mesures moins forte qu un confinement ou
qu'un couvre feu mais des mesures plus
durables à quoi s'attendre alexis
poulain au comme d'habitude des mesures
assez illisible je crois qu'il ya une
véritable fatigue des français de doses
ça suffisait maintenant c'est jamais
deux sans trois et puis après la
troisième en israël déjà les soignants
sont en train de passer à la quatrième
dose on est passé du pass sanitaire au
pass vaccinale maintenant on nous parle
d'un super passe eh bien peut-être qu
après la troisième injection sera au
giga passe au méga passe à la fois lire
les choix de ce conseil sanitaire
devient totalement impossible c'est une
gageur pour les français c'est une
fatigue on voit bien que l'elysée n'a
qu'un but c'est éviter leur confinement
car ce serait l'échec absolu donc il
faut tout faire pour laisser l'économie
ouverte l'école ouverte et en gros au
tous vaccinés tous protégés et bien on a
remplacé le slogan avec le tous vaccinés
tous contaminés puisqu'il s'agit
maintenant pour les cas contactez
soignants ou non de ne pas rester isolé
trop longtemps parce que sinon le pays
seraient bloqués à cent mille cas par
jour si on compte les cas quand actes on
est quasiment 60 millions de cas
contacts donc ça y est ils se sont
rendus compte que c'était impossible
donc on fait une fausse politique
sanitaire qui est de l'extorsion
vaccinale puisque le pass vaccinale
pousse à une vaccination alors que la
vaccination obligatoire ne peut être
décrété donc on voit bien qu'il s'agit
de tourner le bras le poignet des
français certains l'ont fait normalement
pour les deux os puisque c'était la
promesse là et même de ces vaccins
étaient délivrés pour ces deux doses là
on voit bien que tout change à chaque
mois tout change ces trois doses et puis
ce n'est plus si moi ni cinq mois ces
trois mois entre les doses aller
pourquoi pas peut-être quatre doses nous
dit-on du côté des fabricants de vaccins
ou de joe biden quant à olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé c'est très
rassurant lui il ne sait pas s'il faudra
quatre ou cinq doses il est incapable de
répondre donc on est en train de jouer
avec la santé des français parce qu'on
ne sait pas quoi faire d'autre que
vacciner puisqu'on a empêché à la fois
la recherche sur d'autres solutions et
puis la prescription libre de nombreux
médecins qui commence en avoir là aussi
assez de cette politique qui va droit
dans le mur vous l'avez dit 1 ce week
end on a franchi le cap des cent mille
personnes contaminées par l'aco vide 19
c'était samedi est ce que vous ne voyez
dans cette retenue du pas de la part du
gouvernement qu'une qu'un constat
d'échec si jamais il allait plus loin
dans les restrictions qui devait
annoncer tout à l'heure qui devrait être
annoncé tout à l'heure je crois qu'ils
sont très conscients qu'après deux ans
les français ne vont pas obéir il ya une
désobéissance qui se fait jour à la fois
sûrs y compris la troisième dose y
compris en israël 1 où je crois que
c'est plus de 25% ou un tiers de la
population qui n'est pas allé faire la
troisième dose donc on a à peu près le
même cas de figure en france alors les
deux leur demander de faire encore des
autos attestation de respecter des
couvre-feux ou bien pire encore de se re
confiné ils savent très bien que c'est
voué à l'échec les français n'obéiront
plus et là c'est la limite en fait tout
ce qu'on attendait c'était de dire
jusqu'où peuvent-ils poussé dans
l'absurde distant et autoritaire je
crois que c'est là c'est ce moment où ça
craque et on voit bien d'ailleurs à
cette course en avant utilisez les
vacances entre noël et le jour de l'an
pour avancer très très vite dans des
mesures liberticides parce qu'après ce
ne sera plus possible alors il faudra
réveiller les oppositions politiques 1
les parlements assemblée sénat et
assemblée nationale et puis également au
delà des manifestations qui sont dans la
rue mobilisés le corps médical qui doit
dénoncer la politique médicale sanitaire
des malades macron qui est quand même la
france le seul pays à avoir fait mais
fermé plus de 5000 lits pendant cette
crise sanitaire les autres pays n'ont
pas fait ça regardez les autotests il y
a eu pareille pénurie d'autotest la
veille de noël rien n'est prévu on a
affaire à des canard sans tête qui
tourneront qui ne savent pas vraiment
comment gérer cette crise si ce n'est
avec la réaction est avec l'extorsion
vaccinale qui est la seule ligne
directrice maintenant de cette politique
sanitaire sachant que le vaccin on ne
sait pas au delà de trois semaines s'il
protège le booster la troisième dose et
puis on sait maintenant qu'ils
n'empêchent pas de contaminer autour de
soi même si on est vacciné et même si
les vacciner peuvent aussi attrapé ce
virus donc vraiment là je n'arrive plus
à comprendre je crois que la majorité
des français sont dans ce cas là ils
obéissent parce que on n'a pas le choix
mais le exécutif est très conscient que
cette obéissance ne tient plus qu'à un
fil
peut-on dire que passer du pass
sanitaire qui est déjà tout trop versé
au pass vaccinale dont la mise en oeuvre
est prévue dès le mois de janvier au 15
janvier est ce que c'est pas déjà une
mesure suffisamment lourdes pour pouvoir
ensuite imposé aux français d'autres
restrictions pendant ces fêtes de fin
d'année
complètement depuis le début de toute
façon il s'agit d'avancer pas à pas avec
cette fameuse stratégie de l'ingénierie
sociale invendus par les cabinets de
conseil anglo saxons c'est à dire faire
accepter petit à petit l'inacceptable
c'est à dire la fin des libertés
l'enterrement aussi du choix libre et
éclairé aussi de disposer de son propre
corps et le fait de dire que voilà vous
êtes responsable avec cette politique du
bouc émissaire qui est insupportable des
semaines qu'on entend que c'est la faute
des non vaccinés que c'est ce sont eux
qui engorgent les urgences que c'est
vraiment le pire de la société le non
vaccinés est devenu le bouc émissaire de
la politique sanitaire de monsieur
gérant est monsieur macron set
proprement indigne de la part de
républicains d'utiliser cette politique
du bouc émissaire c'est un aveu d'échec
encore une fois sur les fermetures de
lits sur le burn-out général de la
profession soignants pensons à ces
soignants qui n'ont pas pris de vacances
depuis deux ans qu'ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent qui étaient en première ligne
sans vaccin sans protection lors de la
première vague qui ont reçu quelques
accolades des médailles et au final qui
n'ont pas plus de moyens qui sont en
train là aussi de se rendre compte
qu'ils ne pourront pas faire des
miracles et qu'il y aura des morts parce
que c'est une politique criminelle qui a
été mis en place depuis le début merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse alexis
poulain éditorialiste pour rt france
merci à vous